[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a francia que en 2018 fue
escenario de unas multitudinarias
manifestaciones contra los altos costos
de vida hombres y mujeres se reunieron
por primera vez en todo el país su señal
de reconocimiento un chaleco amarillo
meses de intensa protesta social contra
el gobierno de manuel ma con dieron a
este movimiento un carácter inédito
tanto en su duración como en su forma
las manifestaciones fueron violentas y
la represión de las fuerzas del orden se
verá muchos de los que hoy se
autodenominan activistas perdieron un
ojo y manos otros fueron detenidos y
hasta condenados a prisión las denuncias
contra las autoridades por su violento
actuar no han tenido éxito por lo que se
habla de impunidad policial el
movimiento de los chalecos amarillos
nunca tuvo una jerarquía o un
representante oficial pero en ocasiones
algunos han sido designados como
portavoces casi cuatro años después
quienes participaron en el movimiento
cuentan cómo esta lucha ha trastocado
sus vidas
la rotonda de la esperanza e inició casi
cuatro años después del inicio del
movimiento algunos chalecos amarillos
acérrimos siguen ocupando la ahí empezó
el compromiso de aller son bajo un
auxiliar de bodega que actualmente está
desempleado
así como su esquema
y
salimos por el alza de los precios en la
gasolina eso fue lo que despertó a la
gente
hay otras exigencias justicia fiscal
justicia social
el costo elevado de la vida en realidad
nuestras exigencias son siempre las
mismas lo que hemos ganado es que hemos
despertado mucha conciencia
un movimiento profundamente anti marco
la mayoría de las otras corrientes
políticas están representadas y los
debates siguen siendo intensos
más
dice que se
organizan
murió en el cielo yo quise descanso
hay personas que vienen a la rotonda
solo para poder hablar porque están
solas en casa
piensan que no pueden arreglárselas y
aquí nos las arreglamos para compartir
mucho para ayudarnos unos a otros aunque
haya gente que no tenga dinero
el próximo proyecto de álex sounds es la
creación de un gran huerto compartido
las verduras las compartiremos todos
juntos incluso los que no pueden ayudar
demasiado pero los chalecos amarillos
son un poco como una familia en la
ciudad
si bien el movimiento nunca ha tenido
una estructura jerárquica algunas
figuras han sido designadas a veces como
portavoces
es el caso de prisciliano 2 que después
de su petición contra el impuesto al
carbono ella lanzó con algunos otros la
primera movilización el 17 de noviembre
de 2018
el primer día es el que más se enmarcó
porque al principio nos apoyaron
policías discutimos con policías que
decían yo soy un chaleco amarillo debajo
del uniforme no era un activista en
absoluto ni siquiera un movimiento
comunitario o de una asociación
comunitaria aprendí mucho sobre la ira
de la gente en general
vamos amigos retomemos nuestro hilo de
reflexión sobre la ética la política
ahora continúa su formación en la
academia de futuros líderes un programa
creado por personalidades del mundo
asociativo que forma a personas para la
política el objetivo de priscilia es
presentarse a las elecciones
nuestra primera gran línea de
pensamiento pretende poner en tensión
tres conceptos la política de gobernanza
de gestión
recordará que hoy en día la política se
asimila cada vez más a la gestión
al principio del movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos muchos estaban
realmente en contra de entrar en
política al principio era un no rotundo
no confiamos en ellos llegaremos sin
ellos lo que me ha frenado hasta ahora
para entrar en política es que no confío
en las instituciones como mucha gente o
al menos en el sistema pero sábado tras
sábado hubo movilizaciones y entonces
vemos que estamos agotados por la falta
de respuesta política luego las
opiniones empezaron a cambiar sobre todo
durante la crisis sanitaria con las
elecciones municipales vivo surgir y
presentarse listas de ciudadanos de
chalecos amarillo y luego incluso
asociarse a partidos políticos sentimos
que algo había evolucionado
intelectualmente melo clientes cocinaron
ya béisbol como
sin embargo los chalecos amarillos han
hecho todo lo posible para hacerse oír
varias delegaciones se han reunido
incluso con ministros como este 27 de
noviembre de 2018 en el ministerio de
transición ecológica a pesar de ello la
violencia sólo aumenta en todo francia
llegó a parís es la guerra perdonen la
expresión es la primera vez que veo
escenas como esta
la sorpresa dio paso rápidamente a la
acción álex ubago se unió a las filas de
los chalecos amarillos violentos fue
condenado a tres meses de prisión por
atacar a la policía durante las
manifestaciones también pierde sus
derechos civiles durante cinco años y se
le prohíbe salir del país
creo que hay mucho y cada vez expresará
más a través de la violencia sin
violencia nunca se nos escuchará cuando
todo transcurre en calma no se habla de
los chalecos amarillos
en cambio si se habla de nosotros apenas
se produce un acto de vandalismo
desgraciadamente
al salir de la cárcel a alexander se le
prohibió venir a parís y manifestarse
desafía la prohibición la justicia lo
detectó en fotos y videos unos días
después fue detenido de nuevo en su casa
en liso yo me encuentro con 30 policías
con vestimenta militar
cascos escudos con nada más y nada menos
que fusiles de asalto
entran en la casa me tiran al suelo la
cosa más loca me encuentra en la cárcel
y no en una cárcel cualquiera
en un pabellón disciplinario por delitos
menores a los de la primera vez porque
no se me acusa de ningún acto violento
en realidad era más bien para
desmoralizarme para quebrarme me siento
como un yihadista
pues sí
incluso hoy en día se me está vigilando
por radicalización radicalización social
en el primer año del movimiento fueron
detenidas 12.000 personas y otras 400
fueron condenadas a prisión
para otros el precio a pagar fue vivido
en carne propia mi nombre es head y
varín y actualmente me encuentro frente
a la gobernación de pu y en vez de aquí
es donde la policía me reventó un ojo el
1 de diciembre de 2018
al finalizar la mañana de ese día el
grupo de manifestantes entró en el patio
de la gobernación se quedan allí un
tiempo antes de que la policía los saque
algunos manifestantes se resisten
disparan balas de goma granadas
aturdidoras y gases lacrimógenos
cuando se produjo la evacuación me
aparté y me alejé
he venido a pelear ni a nada violento no
quería correr ningún riesgo
fue entonces cuando me explotó una
granada en la cara
me pongo la mano sobre el ojo mientras
se inclinó un poco la cabeza y mi ojo se
cae
si me resbala entre los dedos en un
segundo perdí un ojo una identidad
mi cara estoy desfigurado he perdido mi
trabajo he perdido mi licencia
[Música]
y nunca
más de tres años después y sigue
viviendo con dolor diario pero su
reconstrucción personal está avanzando
gracias
esta es mi prótesis me ha ayudado mucho
a avanzar
hace tiempo que no me la pongo porque me
la tengo que soportar todo el día
esto provoca dolor
puntos de presión frío ardor y picazón
tengo que soportarla
pero también está el hecho de que he
pasado página
me aceptó un poco más como soy sin esta
prótesis
durante las protestas de los chalecos
amarillos otras 28 personas perdieron un
ojo y a 5 les volaron una mano eddie
presentó una denuncia ante la inspección
general de la policía pero como la
inmensa mayoría de los demás mutilados
no tuvo éxito pumas recibió un segundo
gran golpe después de la granada
cuando supe que el caso había sido
desestimado un año y medio después
se menciona el incendio la gobernación
que tuvo lugar por la noche
lo que se supone que justifica el uso de
las armas que me sacaron el ojo
así lo entiendo
a la 1 50 de la tarde no había fuego y
en el momento del incendio estaba
durmiendo en el quirófano nos dijeron
que la violencia policial no existía que
no podíamos hablar de violencia policial
que no había víctimas de violencia
policial de la violencia del estado así
que no puedo existir como víctima y
evitar la violencia policial sin
nombrarla nunca y responder con firmeza
a los agitadores esta es la compleja
ecuación a la que deben responder las
autoridades
y dick de miembros de la crs o control
antidisturbios desde hace más de 25 años
es el director del centro de formación
de lyon su misión enseñar a estos
hombres los cambios tácticos en la
gestión de los manifestantes
el programa cargas ofensivas disparo de
los lanzadores de balas de defensa y
avance en columna
[Aplausos]
una táctica que debe dirigirse a los
manifestantes violentos y evitar las
cargas indiscriminadas cephalon estas
famosas columnas tendrán un impacto en
el dispositivo en profundidad este es el
principio del esquema policial que es a
la vez más protector para los
manifestantes y más firme más duro para
los autores de la violencia
este nuevo esquema policía nacional se
promulgó en 2021 pero sus críticos le
reprochan que no haya hecho ningún
cambio en el uso de las armas
intermedias balas de goma y granadas
steamboat que son la principal causa de
lesiones durante las manifestaciones un
uso necesario de la fuerza para eric
dawan quien estuvo presente en los
campos servicios durante la tercera
movilización de los chalecos amarillos
en este punto a la policía se le salió
de las manos fue un día de disturbios
generalizados con carácter insurrección
al pasamos por situaciones de combate en
vista de la duración del evento ocho
meses de conflicto con concentraciones
en toda francia no podíamos suplir la
demanda y por eso contratamos personal
menos experimentado en técnicas de
primera línea porque no teníamos otra
opción no es fácil mantener el orden
público cuando no se está especializado
como lo estamos
para los chalecos amarillos la violencia
policial se convirtió en una de las
principales preocupaciones durante estas
semanas como en el caso de eddie tras
perder el ojo experimento el activismo
como terapia ese día viajó a parís para
asistir a la jornada internacional
contra la violencia policial
[Aplausos]
nos reunimos entre víctimas de la
violencia de estado entre mutilados
es importante reunirse ayudarse
mutuamente seguir manifestándose juntos
y alzar la voz
[Música]
desde que se decretó el estado de
conmoción durante el mandato de manuel
macrón esta violencia se ha desbocado el
número de muertos y heridos aumenta
exponencialmente
[Aplausos]
muchas emociones se precipitan el
corazón se acelera al ver a tanto
policía que para mí representa el
peligro
miedo rabia que me carcome rabia
destructiva contra la que no puedo hacer
nada
en el lugar se encuentra con su abogada
una oportunidad para revisar el proceso
de su caso para apelar habría que añadir
nuevos documentos al expediente la
abogada espera en particular obtener los
vídeos captados por la policía cuya
granada mutiló a eddie
preguntamos a la fiscalía sobre la
investigación y nos dijeron que no
existía es muy difícil demasiado difícil
y no en vano hablamos hoy de impunidad
policial es que la mayoría de estos
archivos sobre todo cuando no se tienen
vídeos pero incluso cuando se tienen se
refunden hoy en día es casi imposible
reclamar la responsabilidad policial es
necesario que eso cambie unas semanas
después de que se rodará este reportaje
eddie se enteró de que el policía que lo
mutiló había muerto por lo tanto no
habrá recurso al sistema penal ahora se
centra en los tribunales administrativos
en busca de una indemnización económica
por la pérdida de su ojo también con la
esperanza de que le reconozcan como
víctima
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta que nos llevó a francia
a conocer el movimiento de los chalecos
amarillos recuerde que si quiere ver
este y otros episodios en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto